Caleb Martin came through in game seven
to send the heat to the finals and it
might all be because of J Cole no like
Caleb Martin literally gotta try out for
the heat partially because of J Cole
their relationship started back when
Martin was playing for NC State and as a
North Carolina native J Cole was a fan
they stayed in touch throughout Martin's
time on the Hornets and then when Martin
was released back in 2021 J Cole knew he
had to do something so he reached out to
Quran Butler gave Caleb Martin a little
name drop and just like that a try out
for the Miami Heat was Grand Quran did
say that Martin was already on the short
list but since this gave the heat away
to get to Martin without going through
any agents it was an easy decision and
then Martin killed the tryout Jimmy said
he was actually amazing and a two-way
contract quickly followed Martin says
that J Cole still keeps up with every
game